without the support of generous
thoughtful serious donors nationwide
Hillsdale College would not be what it
is
Hillsdale College I daresay would still
decline to take federal funding but it
would shrink in its size it could not
serve nearly as many students as it does
I've come to have an enormous amount of
respect for the independent stance that
the college is taken because to plot a
courage to essentially go it alone to
fuse to accept public money to fund its
operations so Hills what college never
received federal funding we are grateful
for tens of thousands of people who
whether they've seen the college or not
at Lynda to their support students
overall for room board tuition and fees
is $36,000 a year the cost to educate a
student is sixty-eight thousand dollars
a year let me think about it there's an
extra thirty two thousand dollars there
and that's really from our gifts that we
received one of the interesting things
that I know students do is write
thank-you notes to their donors I think
that's a great thing simply because it
personalizes the relationship out of
that gratitude they they thanked their
scholarship donors their benefactors
they write them notes they'd meet them
we love to bring those donors and
students together so they get to know
each other if I could tell a donor
anything
of course to thank them but to let them
know how it blesses each of us as
students to have their generosity I
personally couldn't be here without
donors to the college we wouldn't be
able to do what we do here at such a
high caliber without them these are the
people who allow us to gladly learn and
gladly teach okay that is a huge
blessing
of course gratitude is important